[Musique]
pendant près d'un siècle les mines de
potasse ont façonné les communes au nord
de mulhouse
car oser terrils marque les paysages la
rigueur du travail font dans une
véritable communauté de destin l'arrêt
de l'exploitation au tournant des années
90 aura entraîné le territoire dans la
spirale des classements économiques on
73 y avait encore 13 mai nos emplois en
90 1990 y rester 3500 emplois il fallait
absolument trouver des solutions pour
non seulement réemploi t d des
entreprises le bassin potassique mais
aussi trouver des chantiers d'insertion
en développement pour que les les les
mineurs et les nos mineurs puissent
trouver du travail malgré l'implantation
de nouvelles activités le bassin
potassique reste l'une des zones les
plus préoccupantes du département en
terme de taux de chômage
ainsi sur le bassin ce sont neuf
chantiers d'insertion qui sont créés
nous sommes chez adhésion un des trois
sites mais dans le canton de wittenheim
ici deux structures permettent aux plus
faibles de rebondir au travail une
activité professionnelle
l'atelier vert propose des services de
jardinage et l'atelier du goût rénove et
vend des meubles les ateliers et
chantiers d'insertion sont là pour se
mettre le pied à l'étrier salir les
sortir ses bénéficiaires du chômage et
leur permettre d'avoir un emploi un
contrat de travail de se réinsérer
d'avoir une vie normale
acteur incontournable dans l'insertion
des personnes les plus éloignées de
l'emploi des entreprises un peu
particulière reçoivent le cas des
pouvoirs publics notamment des
départements en charge du rsa ainsi dans
le haut rhin ce sont 10 millions d'euros
qui certainement ses structures et
chantiers sont bien là pour aider à
lever les freins à l'emploi des
personnes des personnes qui sont
bénéficiaires du rsa mais également
d'autres personnes en fonction des
chantiers ou des entreprises d'insertion
qui sont sur le territoire
c'est entre 20 et 60 % de bénéficiaires
du rsa qui qui participent qui sont à
l'emploi dans ces structures d'insertion
d'une durée maximum de 24 mois le
contrat d'insertion n'a pas vocation à
fournir un emploi pérenne mais d'amorcer
une démarche de formation ou de
recherche d'emploi on sait que il
acquiert des habitudes donc se lever
écouter les consignes respectées les
collègues tout ça ce sont des réflexes
qu'ils ne perdent pas et qui peuvent
mettre ensuite en oeuvre dans d'autres
structures
vous connaissez certainement ces
conteneurs installés à wittenheim le
relais est un poids lourd de l'économie
sociale et solidaire ici travail 120
salariés dont 45 en insertion ces
derniers participent à la collecte et à
la valorisation des textiles dans ce
vaste atelier au delà de l'activité
professionnelle le temps qu'il passe au
sein de l'entreprise leur permet de
régler différents problèmes
la priorité c'est de lever les freins
sociaux donc tout difficultés sociales
logement accès au droit etc et dans un
deuxième temps axée sur l'élaboration
d'un projet professionnel
quand on a une stabilité sociale économe
plus confiance en soi on arrive mieux à
trouver du travail à se prendre en main
retrouvé un rythme
il ya plein de choses autour en fait
avant de retourner à l'emploi classique
lui sont maintenant chez idenov à
wittelsheim sept entreprises et
prestataires pour la poste dont elle
entretient les vélos mais sa principale
activité consiste à réparer les autres
d'intervention toutes les lignes haute
tension une activité exigeante car un
simple défaut sur l'une de ses perches
pourrait être source d'un accident
mortel en 2017 l'entreprise a accueilli
13 sérail en insertion et si l'accent
est mis sur la formation
on est ouvert à tous on demande pas de
compétences spécifiques et on est là en
fait pour les formes et donc de par
notre activité on a plusieurs pôles en
fait il ya le quand les outils arrive il
ya du ponçage à faire de la mécanique du
vernis donc plus de la peinture
on essaye de faire tourner tous les
salariés sur les postes pour que
vraiment ils puissent apprendre un
maximum de choses dans le parcours de
deux ans qu'ils font chez nous cette
période de deux ans permettent aussi aux
salariés de se forme dans le cadre de
leur projet de retour à l'emploi au
niveau de la formation voilà par rapport
à ce projet on
à les accompagner dans leur démarche
vers des formations adaptées
alors certaines personnes ont des
projets bien définis en arrivant
d'autres ne savent pas trop ce qu'ils
veulent faire
on essaye de faire au minimum un caces
pour chaque personne et c'est vrai que
ça ça aide à près à la réinsertion dans
le monde du travail classique faut
nettoyer il pas son goût de préparation
et retour sur le site du relais est à
côté de l'atelier textile ce bâtiment
est en chantier
il se prépare à accueillir la nouvelle
structure d'insertion porté par le
relais et terre-à-terre l'objectif c'est
de fans légumerie 100% bio 100% local
donc acheter des légumes brut bio à des
producteurs du coin les éplucher s'il le
faut les laver tout ça par les salariés
en insertion pour les revendre par la
suite à la restauration collective en
grandes surfaces et aux magasins bio au
delà de la question de l'emploi
l'objectif de la légumerie est aussi de
toute vision l'agriculture et du
développement durable notre objectif
c'est bien de mettre en culture des
surfaces dédiées à la légumerie c'est
pourquoi dès la fin d'année 2010 8
on va planifier l'année 2019 avec ses
producteurs pour qu'ils puissent nous
réserve et nous mettre des surfaces en
cultures spécialement pour nous un
projet d'économie sociale et solidaire
qui touche à de nombreux enjeux emploi
économie locale agriculture écologie
mais aussi à l'autre bout de la chaîne
les enjeux de santé publique et
d'éducation
ouf en effet parmi les futurs clients
les cuisines collectives notamment
celles des collèges écoles et lycées où
l'on espère bien voir le bio faire une
percée
une démarche qui pourrait bien avoir un
impact sur toute la chaîne du producteur
au consommateur le département a depuis
longtemps une volonté très forte de
promouvoir une agriculture différente et
le développement durable est donc à ce
titre là ce genre de projet répond à mon
sens tout à fait à aux objectifs du
conseil départemental du haut rhin
pour l'année 2010 8,7 postes vont être
créés d'ici 2020 néanmoins la pérennité
de ces derniers dépendra du succès de
l'opération
même quand elle est sociale et solidaire
l'économie reste est connu la création
d'emplois et le succès de notre
légumerie dépend étroitement de la
volonté politique puisque la
restauration collective est géré au
niveau du département et de la région et
donc on compte sur un soutien des
collectivités pour le succès de notre
activité
le relais est vous donne rendez vous
pour l'ouverture de la légumerie le 2
juillet prochain